[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Hi, everyone.
>> Say, Sir Ronald, welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> We are delighted to have
you with us here today.
And so there's many budding entrepreneur
here in the audience who would be quite
satisfied if they had the one
successful venture under their belt.
But you've not only successfully co
founded five to date and counting but
also established multiple
sectors along the way.
But this wasn't without
encountering many a skeptic.
So can talk us through how you calibrate
the extent to which you should have
courage of your own convictions and ignore
the naysayers versus engage them and
take heed of their warning.
>> So the best way is to start young.
>> Yes. I'm naive. >> And
then think big and then stick with it.
I think with advancing years
you become more skeptical.
Some become cynical.
And my experience has been in developing
venture capital, and then private equity,
and now impact investment.
That you should focus on those
who are enthusiastic, first,
who get it, don't need convincing.
Then there's those who are skeptical,
and you should just avoid the cynics.
>> Interesting.
>> Because those who believe that nothing
new can be done or that nothing should be
done for the first time
are plentiful in our society.
If any of you've been involved
in impact investment and
you know that this isn't something
that everybody immediately picks up.
Never the less it's the future.
And I've just come from Mexico
in Merida which is an hour and
a half away from Mexico City.
400 people gathered from 20
Latin American countries to talk about
impact investment, and
that's just one indication.
I was in Brazil and 600 people came
to a meeting on impact investment.
When you meet with government officials
you find people are aware of the fact that
society can not continue to tackle social
issues in the way that we are doing.
Social for me includes environmental.
So we've come a long way since 2000.
When you find an idea that makes sense,
you think of it becoming global,
you begin to attract inspired people.
When you think small and
deal with the skeptics,
you don't tend to attract inspired people.
And the people who are flocking, it's not
an exact duration to impact investment and
now, are the best and the brightest.
You're an example.
>> That's very kind of you.
I paid him earlier to say that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But on the point of skeptics,
some critics of the valley,
that accuse it of being too insular,
preferring specialists,
and lacking in diversity.
Given that you successfully transferred
ideas between geographies and
between sectors with big society and
social finance.
To what extent do you encourage
the students here to be polymaths,
take the scenic route and
have a multifaceted career,
versus kind of playing to their
strengths early on and focusing?
>> So could I answer that by just
going through some of my history?
>> By all means.
>> And then I'll explain,
perhaps I'll answer your question directly
>> So the reason I got into venture
capital is that a speaker
came to the business school,
General who had been professor
of entrepreneurship,
I guess you'd call it today, at
Harvard Business School, the other place.
And General unlikely figure.
You might think a French military leader
was one of the first venture capitalists.
He invested in and the discussion rather
as I'm speaking to all of you today.
He said look I put $70,000 that
which was digital equipment company,
and it's going public and
my stake's going to be worth $100 million.
That caught my attention.
That's new and interesting.
The time when I was at business school,
the plum jobs were working for
IBM or any of the big, General Motors,
any of the big corporations.
Small was not yet beautiful.
But you felt that
something was in the air.
Intel had just been created,
there was a buzz around semi conductors.
And I felt at that time as I feel today.
That there was something in the air
that was going to be major.
And I decided to go into venture capital.
Now it was a hard slog,
venture capital, in those days.
In the UK people couldn't spell
the word entrepreneur let alone
the word venture capitalists.
>> Well, it's French, so you know.
>> Sorry?
>> It's French.
>> So we try to ignore it.
>> And this is a true story, but one of my
venture capitalist friends took his kid
to interview in a school, for a position
in the school, to join the school.
And the headmaster asked the son, said
you know sonny what does your father do?
He said, he's an adventure copulist.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, it was brand new.
You couldn't even spell it.
Even though some kids had
innovative minds, as you can see.
[LAUGH]
>> And I decided at that time,
look this is big enough and
important enough that I left
Mackenzie after just two years.
I'm going to make a go of this.
And I think this is the future.
Now, if you connect with something which
you feel is going to be there then you
don't need a very long run up for it.
I don't need to say that in Silicon Valley
which has led the way in young
entrepreneurs transforming the world.
And I think when one
talks in terms of should
one devote one's time
to impact investment,
we'll talk about the two strands of
impact investment which are developing.
The one which has to do with
the funding of not-for-profits,
and the one that has to do with the
funding of profit with purpose companies.
If you can connect with something that you
think has real potential in these areas,
then you should connect with it and
get on with it.
If you're unsure about whether or not
you've connected with something like that,
then you're better off
pursuing your career and
acquiring more experience,
until you do that.
And even in the not-for-profit sector
where today a social organization can
build a balance sheet in the same
way that the business can.
That's what impact investment has done.
It's provided layers of capital for
not-for-profits.
The purpose of it was to connect social
entrepreneurs to the capital markets.
And we've done that.
It's an evolution in the idea that we've
got to do more than just make money.
But it's a revolution in the means that
we have brought to not-for-profits
seeking to scale so that they can
tackle social issues effectively.
And if previously we have
all assumed that nothing
can be measured in the social area
>> And of course,
that's true in the sense of valuing
an improvement in a prisoner's life or
an improvement in
a homeless person's life or
an improvement in a diabetic or
prediabetic life.
Any of the 12 social issues that
are now being addressed by the 55
social impact bonds,
which have been launched.
You can't value that, but you can measure
in percentage terms and improvement
verses the past or verses a control
group of people who haven't been helped.
And when you link that
to a financial return,
which represents only a fraction
of the saving to government,
usually in the first year, then you have
something that is extremely powerful.
You begin to have the tools to build
an organization that's motivated to help
others in the same way that you can an
organization that is there to make money.
>> [COUGH]
>> So, on this idea of inclusive
capitalism and this idea around engaging
the invisible heart of the markets
to create opportunities for
those the invisible hand has left behind.
You're clearly a proponent of this is
the market solving these social issues,
but are there any areas whereby you
think markets actually can't so
full and why is that?
>> So, the answer is that not everything
can be measured in the way that I
have described.
There are lots of social issues,
which will continue to be tackled
by not for profits through grants.
We're not trying to displace grants.
What we're trying to do, Nieve is we're
trying to do what we did for business
in areas which improve society and
the planet.
We're trying to connect social
entrepreneurs to capital,
which enables them to harness
entrepreneurship and innovation.
And when in 2000,
I was asked by the Treasury as Charles
mentioned to look at the question
of poverty in Britain and
I started to look at how society
has dealt with social issues.
I discovered some astonishing things.
I discovered that really philanthropists
were the first to tackle social
issues not governments.
In the 19th century, they began to
organize themselves as foundations,
which got tax breaks at the beginning
of the 20th century when all the big
foundations or
many of the big foundations.
Now there are much bigger
ones being set up, but
many of the household name foundations,
The Ford Foundation,
Rockefeller Foundation in the mid 30s, the
Wilcom Foundation in the UK were set up.
By the 1930s, governments were realizing
that philanthropists couldn't
cope with social issues.
Very soon,
were being left behind as economic
growth propelled most of us forward.
Needed help from the government and
governments started to get involved
directly in improving lives.
By the 1940s, we came to the welfare
state, which took on the responsibility
for creating this safety net for
citizens who were more vulnerable.
And today, welfare states
are throwing their hands up.
Across the world, they look at the gap,
a yawning gap between
the provision of social services.
Their ability to pay for
that and likely social needs
with an aging population where the aging
pool is a real challenge in the future.
And so, the idea came to us then on
the Social Investment Task Force.
Venture capital was a response to
the needs of tech entrepreneurs.
It was a major innovation
creating ten year
illiquid funds in order to fund dropouts
with vision was really a new concept and
why can't we find a similar
response to the needs
of social entrepreneurs who
are motivated by empathy to help others?
And I felt, as did my colleagues on
the Social Investment Task Force.
So the way to do that was to
create a social investment bank.
That would bring together people
from the financial world and
people from the social world, and
innovate in making that connection.
Well, if you fast forward that
you've known me ten years.
In 2010,
two young people at Social Finance,
which was founded in the basement
of my office in Portsmouth Place.
We don't have garages for
startups in the UK, we have basements.
It has the advantage that the only
way out of the basement is up.
>> Up.
[LAUGH]
>> So, an increased level of motivation.
And these two young people came to me and
said, we were talking to people
in Birmingham in the UK about
prisoner reoffending more than 60% of
prisoners incarcerated before the age
of 21 in UK and in every other country.
Go back to prison within 18 months and
we came up with the idea of
connecting a reduction in the percentage
that goes back to a financial return.
I said, wow.
That is the key to the capital markets for
social entrepreneurs and
then as we began to work on it with
the Ministry of Justice and we started
pushing numbers, we began to realize
that the cost of the intervention and
it's one of the essential
drivers of impact investment.
The cost of prevention is a fraction
of the saving of that government makes.
And so, we created the first
social impact bonds in
2010 in just three months and
we found ourselves creating a revolution
in the way that prisoners are dealt with.
Does it occur to any of us
that prison management across
the world has no responsibility for
the reoffending rate?
It's unbelievable,
prison management has responsibility for
the cost per prisoner and
the number of incidence in prison.
It's unbelievable.
And when you look at the way
the social sector, the not for
profits help prisoners,
which is what we had to do.
We raised 5 million pounds to fund for
not for profits,
you realize that not for
profits have grown haphazardly
dealing with a specific bit of
the train to achieve an outcome.
To simplify, one not for
profit is helping prisoners in prison.
One's helping them at the gate.
One's helping them get into a job.
One's helping them stay in a job.
No one has responsibility for
achieving the outcome.
And when you begin to get
5 million pounds to say,
let's reduce the rate by 7.5 % plus.
because below 7.5%, the social impact bond
doesn't pay back, doesn't get paid back.
It's just a philanthropic donation.
Let's get a reduction between 7.5 and
a 15% reduction,
so that our investors can make 2 to 13%.
A return on their investment.
You begin to focus on developing
the necessary information,
in the same way that management by
objectives 40 years ago got businesses
to create dashboards and
key performance indicators.
You begin to do the same.
You begin to push for understanding
how you deal with the accommodation
problem that 40% of prisoners face,
they don't know where they
are going to spend the night.
The 18% that still have a drug habit,
the 25%
that has insufficient money to make it
through to the first government pay check.
And so what's happening is a prisoner
gets to the prison gates with those three
issues and the drug dealer meets them
at the gate and says come, I'll give
you a place to sleep and something
to forget what you've been through.
And they're back in,
two-thirds of them are back in prison.
I take this example because
the cost of intervention
is probably about a third of a saving
the government makes in the first year.
The investors in the first social impact
bond will make 7%, the government who's
changed the whole of the probation office,
not necessarily in the best way possible,
but probably as a result
of the focus on prisoners.
Which, and prisoner rehabilitation,
which the social impact bond brought.
And so when you look at 55 social impact
bonds today across the world, across
a dozen countries, two were announced in
the last few days in the United States.
A $30 million South Carolina
social impact bond
to prevent teenage pregnancies,
or reduce teenage pregnancies.
A $12 and a half million social
impact bond in Connecticut
dealing with unstable families
plagued by drug abuse.
When you begin to look at how homelessness
is being tackled, how primary drop
out rates from primary school in India is
being tackled, how drop out rates from
computer studies at college level
in Israel is being tackled.
When you look at unemployed
youth in the UK,
and the way that social impact bonds
have funded organizations that help them
acquire the skills to get into jobs,
you begin to feel that this is
really bringing about a revolution in
the way that we tackle social issues.
But as you know, Maeve,
it's only the beginning of the revolution.
>> And on that point, so
how do you see the sector as
a whole evolving going forward?
What are the new models that are emerging?
And who are the key players
that are driving change today?
The next Bill yourself?
>> So, the social impact bond brought
us to the realization that measurement
is actually central to tackling social and
environmental issues.
And that you can connect it to a financial
return and access the capital markets.
There are investors who will say, wow 7%
uncorrelated return with the stock markets
and interest rates, because you don't
know what the bond is going to pay until
later in it's life, that's pretty cool.
People would put five,
ten percent of their portfolio in
absolute return instruments of this kind.
But when we created the G8 task force,
and we had 200 people
across the world involved through
national advisory boards,
Matt Banick of Medea was one of
my close partners in this effort.
And people like Matt and
Tracey Polantron of social finance,
who together led the National
Advisory Board in the United States.
People like that across the G7
countries plus Australia
brought all of their know-how about social
issues and finance to the task force.
And we realized that something much
more fundamental was happening than just
innovating with an instrument.
We realized then that
the world had shifted,
if in the 19th century the world
measured financial return,
Adam Smith and before,
all the way through to the 19th century.
In the 20th century, we have innovated
by measuring risk and return and
by opening the window on
risk we created a need for
new concepts like diversification.
Which led to the notion which
the endowments lead, including Stanford,
that you can include in a diversified
portfolio high risk assets.
Which may be a bit more volatile but
you yield much better returns and
improve the return on your portfolio,
then in
the 21st century we were already
measuring risk return and impact.
Only people haven't realized it fully.
Those who are unpopular today,
be they in the financial services area,
or utilities like electricity
generation companies,
are unpopular because they're perceived
as having negative impact on society.
A utility per se is not an unpopular
company but the utility
which is deemed to charge its customers
more than it should if they are poor and
to account for a big percentage of their
disposable income is judged negatively.
And when you begin to measure
impact alongside risk and
return you open the window again
on a new set of opportunities.
Themes in the profit with purpose area,
for instance.
Such as The Gym in the UK or
Tom Shoes in the United States or
Warby Parker or Esty.
When my colleagues at Bridges started to
look at how can we improve the health
of people living in poor areas
the answer was we should create gyms.
But if you create a gym in a poor
area it has to be open 24/7.
It has to be large, because you’re
going to charge a quarter of
what you can charge in
the main stream economy.
So it's a 15,000 square foot gym.
No membership fee and no frills,
no changing rooms, no jacuzzi, no spa.
The gym floated for 250 million pounds
just a few months ago in the UK.
Several thousand members,
are joining before the gym opens.
30 to 40% of the members have never
been able to afford a gym before.
So what's the window you're opening?
You're opening a window on themes,
that say, if I come up with a product or
a service at a low cost, which is capable
of satisfying huge latent demand.
I can grow it faster than
a mainstream business.
And so, what is beginning to happen
today is that the measurement of risk,
return, and impact is beginning
to lead to a revolution in
the types of business models that
entrepreneurs are developing.
And these two streams,
the funding of not for
profits to achieve social
goals Which works better when
the communities help is
required in rehabilitating
a prisoner or absorbing a homeless person.
And the other stream of profit with
purpose, which works better where you're
developing products and
services that can generate cash flow and
take advantage of high growth.
Those two streams of coming together
at the same time as social and
environmental coming together.
And we're beginning to see
governments across the world saying,
we can't cope,
we need money from the capital markets.
It's entrepreneurs who're
going to come with innovation and
how we tackle social issues.
Who are going to fund prevention
that we need to bring in.
And so country by country we're
beginning to see governments
introducing incentives for this.
>> So regarding governments,
by their very nature they're transitional
both in terms of the stakeholders and
the agenda.
So how do you ensure that you
manage to maintain momentum and
push your initiatives through to
completion given all the ongoing change?
>> Well that's the great strength of
instruments like social impact bonds.
Because as Iain Duncan Smith, one of our
senior ministers in government today,
in charge of the department of works and
pensions puts it, when you sign up for
a social impact bond, you get what's
written on the tin as he puts it.
The way he expresses it is,
look, I come in as a minister.
I have great intentions.
I want to make something happen.
We develop the idea.
Some of my officials who always wanted to
do something specific tried to add it in.
Some of my officials who
hate something take it out.
And then there's an election and
I'm gone and
the program continues badly designed for
decades and nothing much comes from it.
With the social impact bond, when you
sign a contract with the investors to put
money up on the basis of which
there are social metrics
which are going to mean that
your performance is objectively
audited and you're paid out according
to that, you can't deviate from it.
It has to run the seven years,
or the five years, or
the ten years of the social impact bond.
And it's the way for
us to create benchmarks and
innovate in the way that
we tackle social issues so
as to improve the delivery
of government services.
It's not to substitute for government.
It's an instrument where government,
most of the time, pays out on results.
Sometimes foundations
will pay out on results.
Sometimes health management
organizations will pay out.
Sometimes universities will pay out as
in the Computer studies dropout example.
But fundamentally, you're innovating
in the way we tackle social issues and
you're setting benchmarks
which government then
can take into account in
formulating it's own policy.
>> Yeah.
Some of the issues today,
sadly, are just so complex.
The current refugee
crisis being one of them.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, given all of your success to date,
many here may not know how you arose to be
in the UK to go on to Oxford and beyond.
And this I think the story is
especially poignant with its
backdrop of the refugee crisis.
So I was wondering if you'd be so
kind as to kindly share with us
as why your family fled Egypt.
And what it was like as an 11
year boy arriving in Britain,
speaking no English, ten pounds in
the pocket and just a suitcase each.
Sorry.
>> Well, it was interesting.
[LAUGH] I had my stamp
collection under my arm.
And I was very worried that it would be
taken away from me as I was leaving Egypt.
I have very good memories of
Egypt as a very liberal place.
I went to a Catholic school
where on Fridays you could go to
the Catholic service or
the Muslim service or the Jewish service.
It was the Friars of St. John the Baptist,
one of the best schools in Egypt.
And the reason that we were kicked out
of Egypt is there was something called
the Suez Crisis, which might seem like
the dim and distant past to many of you.
It occurred in 1956.
When Nasser nationalized, Nasser who
was then the president of Egypt,
nationalized the Suez Canal.
And Britain, which owned the canal,
France, which built it, and Israel,
which felt threatened by Nasser,
united to take the canal out.
And the United States,
under pressure from Russia,
intervened and stopped that operation.
And Nasser retaliated by expelling
all British and French citizens.
And made it very uncomfortable for
Jews to stay, basically.
And if you were an Egyptian Jew,
as I was and
my family was, then when you left,
you lost your Egyptian nationality.
And there were only three places that
would take you as a stateless citizen.
Brazil, Canada, and Australia.
But my mother had a British
passport by quirk of fate.
And we were on our way to Rio de Janeiro.
And we stopped in Milan to catch
the boat in Genoa, to Rio de Janeiro.
And my mother said I'm going to my dad,
I'm going to, he couldn't travel
because he was stateless.
Said I'm going to take the kids and go to
London, and say goodbye to my brothers.
And when she got to London, she found my
dad and said, we're staying right here.
This is where you're going to
get the best education for
the kids, this is the place to be.
What are we going to go and
do in Brazil miles away from Europe and so
on and do forth?
My dad spoke English.
Happily agreed, it was difficult for him
to disagree, with my mother who was a very
forceful person and so we became British.
>> But
we're delighted to have adopted you.
[LAUGH]
>> I've been,
I've been blessed, to be British.
And Britain has been extremely good to me.
And one interesting quirk,
is that the Henry Fellowship,
which I got to
Harvard Business School from Oxford,
obligated me to come back to
Britain with something of value.
And the thing I came back with was venture
capital from Harvard Business School.
So these things matter.
So what was it like?
Well my parents turned
it into a challenge.
My dad was very sad to
lose everything in Egypt.
My mother, who was more down to Earth,
thought Egypt was going to have
a very difficult time, and
that this was a blessing in disguise,
which it turned out to be.
So, I viewed it as a challenge, and
I happened to be a good student,
and actually the education I'd had in this
Catholic school stood me in good stead.
And so, I made it into Oxford
because of one teacher.
>> A history teacher.
>> Richard Farley.
>> Richard Farley, a history teacher.
Who said to me, Cohen,
you should be going to Oxford.
And he prepared me for the entrance exams.
In those days you had
a series of entrance exams.
That school had only sent
one person to Oxford before.
And Richard Folly trained a few of us,
and four of us got into Oxford.
>> It's a real life case
of The History Boys.
>> Absolutely.
And then I look for
Richard Farley for years, and
I found him 40 years after I'd
left Orange Hill Grammar School
because I remembered he'd
written a book on education.
And that his publisher
must have his address, and
sure enough, that was the case.
And so I was privileged to reconnect
with him and visit him once or
twice a year, and the most wonderful,
just the most wonderful man.
So, when you talk of the immigrant crisis,
I have empathy.
Not that I had to go
through the tribulations
of the Syrian immigrants that we see
today, by the way, another quirk of fate.
My grandparents were born in Aleppo,
in Syria and
came down to Egypt when the Suez Canal was
opened because the caravan routes going
through Aleppo died, and all the merchants
went into the Lebanon or to Egypt.
And I think that we have an obligation
to deal with displaced people.
Not just because we don't have
the choice of ignoring it.
You can't have millions of
people spreading through
society not being looked after without
terrible implications for society.
But I think, it's a moral obligation
we have to help those in need.
And one of the efforts I'm making
is to create at central level
in the EU a billion dollar fund to pay out
on social impact bonds which are going
to fund o organizations that can
help the absorption of immigrants.
>> That's wonderful.
Another body that you've
greatly support and
trust which seeks to encourage
private sector in both Israel and
Palestine as a means to
peace in the Middle East.
>> Yep.
>> Can you talk us through
how business can or
should help resolve conflict?
>> So, there are two people in
the audience, Afir Sampson and
Travis Hollingsworth.
Afir worked with me in Israel
at the Portland Trust and
Travis worked with me
at Big Society Capital.
And I think you know they are examples
of people who feel that one can make a
difference by following these approaches.
And that you can do good and
do well at the same time.
The innovation that is coming now is
coming because there are very powerful
drivers as I have said, governments
on the one hand don't have the money.
The millennial generation,
of which you're a part,
that feels that it wants to
do more than just make money.
And investors who to the tune
of $55 trillion, have
signed up to the United Nations Principles
of Responsible Investments saying,
we owe it to generate more
than just financial returns.
And social sector organizations, not for
profits, that say to
themselves we want to grow.
If we're helping 700 homeless people
in the UK we'd like to help 7,000 or
30,000 or 50,000 homeless people
at any given time in the UK.
These are powerful drivers, and
I think the fundamental change
that has come is to say,
the allocation of resources
in financial terms,
in terms of the human capital that
you all represent here today,
cannot come just on the basis of risk and
return.
I think being a business that's in it for
just money is not going to
be a popular business.
Already, if you want to attract
the greatest talent in places like
McKenzie and elsewhere,
you have to elevate the goals.
You have to give the opportunity
to entrance to do
things that are going to improve society.
And so the transformation that is
going to come through business,
is going to start as the tech
revolution did, is going to start
with the destructors who are young, and
who say, I'm going to create the business
which is going to deliver the best
combination of risk, return, and impact.
And I'm going to attract the most talented
people because it's a more inspiring goal.
And it'll pull behind it,
just tech did the big corporates,
some of which are reacting today.
I was at the launch 125 million euro
impact fund,
launched by the Mars Corporation and
the Danone Food Corporation in France,
two huge food corporations.
To take a million people in their
supply chain out of poverty.
Unilever is beginning to publish a set of
social objectives for itself as a company.
And big companies will follow.
If you look ahead 20 years,
I know Einstein said, the future is
unknowable, but it's not unthinkable.
So let's think,
as we think together look ahead 20 years.
We can envisage impact public equities,
impact fixed income,
impact venture capital,
impact private equity,
impact real estate, and
impact absolute return.
Where will the money go?
If investors then have the choice between
a company that delivers a 20 percent
IRA as an investment, and another company
that delivers a 20 percent IRA and
a 35 percent social return,
measured because governments publish
as the UK is already doing the cost
of social issues on the web.
You go to the cabinet office website, you
will find the cost of 640 social issues.
You'll be able to work out that the young
prisoner I was talking about is costing
the government 22,000 pounds a year.
And you rehabilitate
1,000 it's 22 million.
And 22 million on a 5 million social
impact bond over seven years is
more than 35% IRA rule, or whatever.
Where'd you think the money's going to go?
Is it going to go to those who are just
building a business to make money?
Or is it going to go to those who
are able to deliver a social return,
or an environmental return?
At the same time, so that's why we called
our report of the G8 task force
the The Invisible Heart of Markets.
Because the Invisible Heart of Markets
is the measurement of impact, and
it will guide their invisible hand.
And there's a wonderful, historic element,
and it is that Adam Smith
was prouder of his book,
The Theory of Moral Sentiments,
which is all about why
People help out of empathy.
Then he was out of the wealth of nations.
And if he'd been around, he'd have coined
the phrase the Invisible Heart of Markets.
>> That's wonderful.
So on the note of thinking the future and
getting our collective minds together,
we'll turn to the audience for
any questions you may have.
So, Gracie and
Mariel will be rooming with the mics,
so if you can just put up your hand,
and they'll come to you.
I think Charlie's got one at the back
there, straight off the bat.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> The mic will come to you in one second.
>> Thank you very much for the words.
I did my undergrad at
Exeter College as well,
and so benefited from your support there.
>> Really?
>> So, thank you for that too.
My question was about
your political views,
and I guess based on your close
link to the Labour Party in the UK,
whether the advancement of impact
investing had changed those views?
A, in terms of what it means for
the role of the government, and
B, with how receptive different
political parties are to it.
Great to meet somebody
who's an Exterian as I am.
>> Yeah, I just count all
the Brits just among the audience.
>> I owe a lot to ExeterCollege.
You can imagine what it's like seven years
after coming to Britain as a refugee.
To walk into the quad of a college
founded in 1314 with illustrious
people who had gone there
before was a real privilege.
When I was a student at Oxford,
where I was very involved in politics.
I was president of the Oxford Union,
which was a debating society.
As a liberal,
I was a liberal for 30 years.
The liberals were in the center
between the Labour Party and
the Conservative Party.
When Tony Black came in, I became
a Labour Party supporter because he
adopted the policies that I believed in.
And when David Cameron came in,
the Cameron Government called me and
said, will you come and
lead the social investments?
And another social investment task force.
Will you come to set up at
The Social Investment Bank
that you recommended in 2000.
And if you do,
and you can put together an intelligent
plan for a Social Investment Bank
we will allow you to take all of
the unclaimed assets you asked for.
We have focused in 2005 asking for
government who was then trying
to take away bank accounts
that had been separated from their owners
for 15 years or more from the banks.
The banks hold on to this money.
And the Labour Government said to me,
we'll give you 75 million pounds,
rather than the 250 million pounds you
were asking for as equity for this bank.
We said, well we start with a couple
million pounds of philanthropic
money while we think about it, because 75
million pounds ain't a lot of money in
financial terms when you're dealing with
the social issues we're talking about.
A cut a long story short, the Conservative
Government allowed us to start the first
Social Investment Bank, independent of
government, with just one government
representative at the trust level
which looks to keeping it on mission.
With a 600 million pounds,
a billion dollars of which 400
million pounds came from unclaimed assets,
and I found the Conservative Government
was completely sold on
the idea of the big society,
which was basically saying that you
have a big government that can't cope.
You need the society to do it, only we
didn't know how society could do it.
And the Social Investment Bank
was the first tangible
expression of what the big
society program really was.
So, then I began to work very closely
with the Conservative Government.
And I like to say that I'm about
policy rather than politics, and
this issue of impact investment whether
it's in the United States where the two
social impact bombs were launched in the
democratic state and the republican state.
Or whether it's in the UK, we've
managed to keep it a bipartisan issue.
To stress for those who like market forces
and for those who, on the other hand,
feel the state should be responsible for
all of these things that this does both.
It improves government, and
it bring entrepreneurship and capital and
market forces at attacking social issues.
>> Since Dave is braze nose
chap from Oxford, so am I,
I'm happy you gave him a shout out.
Next question.
So, yeah.
>> Okay.
Hi, my name is Mario, I'm Mexican.
How do you think about the line that
divides what is impact investing,
and what is not?
To me, any business that makes profit,
is creating jobs, is creating innovation,
and advancing society.
Many things could be argued against
tobacco, alcohol, what not.
Yeah, how do you think about that line?
>> So, there's a big distinction
we made in the G8 Task Force
report between investment with impact and
impact investment.
We are all in favor of
investment with impact.
Businesses that's create jobs,
improve lives in their communities.
But that's not going to deal with
social issues in the way we need.
Impact investment is investments where you
have measurable social or environmental
goals set, and you measure their
achievement alongside financial return.
And that is going to create the innovation
that will lead to a revolution.
And so we see impact investment
sitting between philanthropy
on the right-hand side which will begin
to measure much more as it gives grants.
But we'll see its own
business model disrupted.
I'll talk about that in a moment.
And what we might call ESG, environmental
social governance, on the left hand side.
Or social responsible investment or SCR.
Where basically businesses
intend to do good but
don't set measurable objectives and
measure their achievement.
Intention is not enough.
We're living in a time when
intention has evolved, and
the intention just to make
money is no longer sufficient.
You need to do more than that.
But the revolution is coming
by bringing the means
that didn't exist before
to tackle social issues.
And so I think what we're going to find
over time is that those businesses
in the middle which are businesses
that set social and environmental,
as well as financial objectives and
to those not-for-profits that innovate.
By creating measurable goals through
social impact bonds and in other ways,
will bring the innovation required
to improve people's lives.
And that will begin to
affect the businesses and
the philanthropists on the other side.
One of the great parallels for me,
who lived through the Tech revolution and
Silicon Valley has scored
most of the goals.
But we invested in the company,
in that revolution,
that cloned Dolly the sheep in the UK.
It's one of the only companies out of
Europe that made it to the hundred most
important companies of the 20th century.
We lost all our money but,
>> [LAUGH]
>> it was a great thing to do.
It's bringing a revolution in medicine.
I think we're going to find people now
who say I want to be the Microsoft
of improving education.
Or I want to be the Apple
of improving health, and
I'm going to innovate in
the way that I do it.
The disruption that is happening is right
across all the constituents of our world.
So when Jeff Riggs who was CEO
of the Gates Foundation says
the business model of philanthropy is
being disrupted, what does he mean?
He means in the future philanthropists
are going to measure results for
the grants program.
They're going to make commitments to
outcomes funds that pay out on social
impact bonds and development impact bonds,
when the outcomes are reached, and
they're going to invest from their
endowment a certain percentage.
We're asking for 10% now.
In investment opportunities that have the
right balance of risk, return and impact.
You look at the disruption to
the business model of entrepreneurs,
businesses are going to raise capital
on the basis of achieving financial and
social environmental goals.
You look at the disruption at the level
of social sector organizations.
They're going to be able
to build a balance sheet.
We already see six not for profit
service delivery providers in the the UK
with sales of more than 50 million pounds.
I don't know if you saw the figures
in the Dan Pallotta TED Talk, that in
25 years in the States, 50,000 businesses
made it through 50 million of sales.
And only 144 not for profits.
So you have disruption coming to social
sector organizations that's been scaled
and fund innovation.
And you have disruption from governments
which begin to measure outcomes,
instead of just paying for inputs.
And which attract capital
to fund innovation
from investors who take
the risk of failure,
because they are motivated by
a blended financial and social return.
So for me, this impact revolution
is going to be as pervasive as
the tech revolution has been, and
it's going to be led by the likes of you.
You're the ones who
are going to innovate and
you're the ones who are going to
scale this in such a way that we do
a better job of improving people's lives
than we've been able to do until now.
>> So I think some of our professors
like Matt Ballack who teaches here and
Heidi and Charles would be quite delighted
that you have just reenforced all of
the teachings they've been trying to
force on us the past couple of weeks.
>> Well Matt has been my partner,
one of my partners,
very close partners in the task force and
now the global steering group
of 13 countries plus the EU,
which has succeeded for Task Force.
>> So Sir Ronald, I get the privilege
of asking the last question.
And as you alluded to earlier, you used to
be the President of the Oxford Union, so
back in the day you were in my seat,
inviting the thought leaders to share
their thoughts, such as Bobby Kennedy.
I was just wondering were there any pearls
of wisdom that particularly resonated and
stayed with you, that you would
like to share with us today.
>> I think it's right to be idealistic.
I think when people say you shouldn't
be idealistic, they're really concerned
about their ability to be successful and
to be idealistic at the same time.
And I think the two
are totally consistent.
I got into venture capital because
I thought it was socially good.
Britain had 3 million unemployed, and
I thought it was a good thing to do.
And it created a lot of jobs, and it
improved competitiveness of the country,
and it improved the average
standard of living.
But it really didn't bridge
the gaps between rich and poor.
What we've discovered is that
two slogans of my generation.
Growth will cure economic ills and
the quality of opportunity,
turned out to be empty slogans for
those whom society leaves behind.
Economic growth creates an even
bigger gap between rich and poor.
And equality of opportunity is
an empty phrase for somebody born into
a family where both parents
are unemployed and have a drug habit.
Unless we begin to focus on improving
the quality of our society,
our societies are going to break apart.
We already see major divides
occurring within our cities,
within our countries, within regions.
And I think the zeitgeist today,
unlike the zeitgeist in 1977 to 69 when
I was where you are sitting now,
which is smallest
is going to be beautiful and innovation
is going to become from technology.
The zeitgeist today is being
impactful is going to be beautiful.
And being impactful is going to
change our lives in the same way that
technology has done.
>> Well on that positive note,
please join me in thanking Sir Ronald.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]